no hay trigo en jartum
la ciudad sigue siendo escenario de
explosiones y sangrientos
enfrentamientos por lo que la ayuda
humanitaria tiene problemas para llegar
en su camino hacia darfur en el oeste
del país todos los convoyes fueron
saqueados este fracaso fue considerado
inaceptable por la ONU que ahora exige
garantías para la entrega segura de
ayuda en la zona de combate
tenemos que ser muy claros sobre los
compromisos adquiridos para garantizar
el flujo seguro de suministros desde
todo Sudán o chat a darfurt estos
compromisos son una prioridad absoluta
para mí y ya hemos iniciado
conversaciones con las partes para
determinar Qué necesitamos de ellas
en darfurt los combates han dejado un
centenar de Muertos desde la semana
pasada el caos ya reinaba en esta región
desde un sangriento conflicto étnico en
la década de 2000 en 2003 bajo el
régimen dictatorial de Omar albahachir
estalló en darfur un conflicto genocida
hoy Naciones Unidas teme que los
combates militares revivan el pasado de
las masacres en las que murieron hasta
300.000 personas en dark
un país como Sudán que ha sufrido tanto
no puede permitirse una lucha de poder
entre dos personas
según la ONU actualmente hay en Sudán al
menos 330.000 desplazados internos y se
calcula que unas 100.000 personas han
huido los países vecinos Egipto chat y
Etiopía